christmas morning in the ramsey
household always starts with a late
breakfast of deliciously creamy
scrambled eggs and smoked salmon this
recipe is a ramsey family tradition on
christmas day
smoked salmon scrambled egg and
croissant it's rich sumptuous and
incredibly easy to do
first the croissants slice them into
rounds and season them lightly with salt
and pepper the secret behind a really
good breakfast
is in the timing
all the questions on first smoked salmon
on top and then the scrambled egg put
the quetzals in a dry pan and toast you
don't need oil because the questions
have a lot of butter in them
this is a great way to transform day old
croissants giving them a delicious new
life
just start to see them toasting
almost listening
in the pan and that's the butter
inside that smell
is amazing almost smells like a sort of
caramelized waffle
absolutely delicious toast them all
around
both sides
and then out
next
just get the smoked salmon and sort of
twist it
and let it fall
over the question
let it sit
naturally
on top of the toasted cressel
[Applause]
a little twist
and over
right scrambled eggs
eggs into the pan
never whip up the eggs beforehand
you break down the egg too much what i
want is really nice rich creamy
scrambled egg eggs in no seasoning at
this stage a nice generous knob
of butter
now
from there
onto the heat and all we're going to do
now is stir
stir and stir and stir
[Music]
now the butter's melting
and it's giving a really nice creamy
texture
to the eggs
it looks rich
delicious sumptuous luxurious
if you're very careful making scrambled
eggs all of a sudden it looks runny and
within 30 seconds it's cooked
working it all the time
right after stirring i place this
scraper in there take the pan off the
heat
and just work
round the pan cleaning up all that
scrambled egg that's sticking to the
bottom and now look we're getting that
really nice sort of creamy
beautiful texture a little touch of
butter in there
now
i'm going to start with the seasoning
30 seconds on the end salt pepper
back on
to the stove and a tablespoon
of cream
the cream
actually stops
the scrambled egg from overcooking
cream in and then fold that in there
now keep that off the heat
but look at it look at that color
beautiful
and then finally
some fresh chives
[Music]
that
is a ramsay classic smoked salmon
toasted crescent and a delicious
scrambled egg
the best start to christmas day anyone
could wish for
christmas is a really expensive time but
with a little understanding of finesse
you can use up every edible part of your
christmas shopping just like we do in my
restaurant kitchens otherwise it's money
down the drain
[Music]
soups are one of the secrets in a chef's
arsenal for delivering amazing flavor
whilst watching the pennies
my next recipe for sumptuous pumpkin
soup uses the whole pumpkin the leftover
hamstock and i'm getting the kids
involved toasting the pumpkin seeds as a
snack nothing goes to waste in my
kitchen
but most importantly of all the soup
tastes absolutely delicious
and with the addition of sauteed wild
mushrooms it's fit to serve in my three
mission style restaurant
right
listen i need some help okay we're gonna
make the most amazing pumpkin soup feel
that's heavy it's very heavy
but it is gonna be absolutely delicious
right you can always tell
okay if it's ripe
[Music]
what does that sound like um
drums that's right and if you push your
thumb in there
it should be just a little bit soft
right at the bottom of the root yeah
right first of all i'm going to cut it
in half and very carefully just cut
through i'm using a french pumpkin
but these versatile vegetables come in
all shapes and sizes and colors at this
time of year their nutty sweetness is
ideal for warming soups curries and
roasts
wait and see what happens when we open
this up wow
right holly that's for you
now this is where it's going to get a
little bit gory okay you get your hands
and you scrape the seeds out
i like getting messy rub them together
and just give them a little clean nice
and gently good
yeah nice
look at that yuck what do you mean yuck
come on holly that's it into the water
now once the seeds are out we're going
to toast them in the oven as a little
snack so this is a really nice way i'm
not wasting anything
get your fingers right in there tilly
there you go
[Music]
once the pumpkin seeds are out score the
flesh to help it roast and absorb flavor
season and add a generous amount of
rosemary
take the garlic rub around the outside
so it perfumes the inside
then add a large glug of olive oil
and as the garlic grows with the
rosemary its sweet almost buttery nutty
taste will mellow and flavor the pumpkin
all the seeds done
yeah almost good
after the pumpkin seeds have been
cleaned dry and season them ready for
the oven
now they're gonna roast
in the oven for about 45
to 50 minutes
well done
good
and wait smell the house in about five
minutes time tray please holly
so
beautiful straight in right well done uh
big question have you wrapped mummy's
present yet
no let's go i'll give you a hand quickly
got that garlic smells amazing
[Music]
holly
tilly where's holly she's going to a
party she's going to a party oh no any
boys there
i don't know oh you're so diplomatic
right
look
they
are now toasted
hear that
right have a little taste one of those
nice yeah
but look at this wow
that
looks amazing and that is your roasted
pumpkin
now
you put the spoon down the side
okay yeah scooping out
all that lovely
roast pumpkin
we don't waste anything
eat that skin all into the center
roasting a pumpkin intensifies the rich
sweet flavor of its flesh which is
lovely for soups but also great as a
filling for ravioli or making a
delicious mash with butter nutmeg and
salt and pepper that's the pumpkin done
now what i want you to do is get these
mushrooms here and just peel them
lengthways okay onto the plate
okay and i'll get my onion
chopped olive oil in
okay
nice and generous with the olive oil
because i want this soup to be really
nice and velvety onions in
[Music]
and then scoop out
that wonderful garlic that's been
roasted
on the pumpkin
lovely little bit of nutmeg on top of
the onions
onions garlic nutmeg yeah
and now the pumpkin
say that
and you would come in handy somewhere
this little baby
it's for you there you go
perfect
now i want you just to grate some
parmesan like that for me
okay
just so i can start roasting off the
parmesan as well so we get this really
nice rich
delicious
pumpkin
parmesan's brilliant for enriching this
soup it's mellow caramel flavour and
saltiness provide a lovely balance to
the sweet pumpkin now what i want you to
do
is dip all that in there
okay
yeah
good
[Music]
look at that now
that
huh
[Music]
roasted sort of cheesy rosemary
garlicky yeah
olive oily beautiful so far nothing's
gone to waste we've used the whole
pumpkin now i'm gonna add the stock my
hand was cooked in
it smells like cinnamon it doesn't
doesn't it smells christmassy
delicious
that's just from cooking our ham
bring that up to the boil
we'll let that cook out for 10 minutes
cream really important that it's boiling
when the cream goes in
okay you'll see the color lightening
so that's going to give it a really nice
rich
creamy taste
okay now we're going to study the
mushrooms a little olive oil in there
yeah
get nice and hot
we'll go first with the trumpet de la
more there you go
good girl then the
pier mutong
in
and then finally chanterelle
nice lovely i want to put a little bit
of butter in there
don't forget
good girl
a little bit better there nice
i love the deep complex flavor of wild
mushrooms but if you can't get them
chestnut or filled mushrooms still
deliver great taste
mushrooms work really well with pumpkin
because they have a warm earthy flavor
that complements the pumpkin beautifully
so
mushrooms
into the center
yeah
from there
we get the parmesan
and just peel nice long layers
watch very carefully no
just sit there on top on the parmesan
helps to season the mushroom
and really
give off
an amazing flavor
okay
we're going to blend the soup and what
we're going to do
is half fill
the blender
so the soup gets really nicely aerated
now there's a bit of a naughty chef's
trick
a little knobber butter in there
just in top so when it blends
it gets really nice and smooth lid on
onto the blender
and we'll just pulse it on and off first
nice
wow
and this is the moment we'll be waiting
for
just one side of the bowl
so that's daddy's portion
that
this little bit is yours
now
a little taste blow gently
[Music]
to keep things fresh and interesting
chefs have to be open to new ideas so
we're always looking to innovate or
update old recipes my next chef's secret
for the ultimate christmas is give your
classic christmas recipes a nice revamp
because i work long and unsociable hours
throughout the year i really look
forward to catching up with friends and
family during the christmas holidays
it's a time to be sociable parties
drinks guests dropping by
and having a warming jug of aromatic
mulled wine and some spiced nuts on hand
really puts everyone in the christmas
spirit
love that sound
christmas is here
mulled wine is a real christmas classic
but i'm going to give it a modern 21st
century twist
first pour red wine into a pan and
gently heat
now i'm gonna make a fragrant bouquet
garni basically a really nice aromatic
tea bag
muslin cloth absolutely perfect for this
if you haven't got muslin cloth a brand
new j cloth is just as good
now first off cardamom pods
they are incredibly aromatic and more
importantly gives a really nice dense
spicy flavor
next add a pinch of cloves close the
dried flower buds and add a lovely
pungent sweet flavor
then drop in a couple of star anise
which adds an aniseed note
a cinnamon stick
cinnamon sticks are made from the bark
of trees native to sri lanka break one
in and this gives a warm sweet spice to
the wine
lemongrass so this makes it slightly
asian here a little bit more sort of
exciting but gives a really nice light
twist to the wine
i'm gonna do first is just press down
on the lemongrass
and what that does
it starts to release all that oil and
flavor once it's crushed just cut it
over
the muslin cloth
once all your spices are in fold up the
muzzling cloth and tie tightly
and look
that
is like a little miniature
perfect chest pillow into the wine
next add orange zest twist
then cut the orange into wedges and pop
those in too
to sweeten the wine put in a tablespoon
of demerara sugar
next stem ginger
gives the mulled wine a little bit of a
sort of kick
almost like that really nice sort of
ginger beer aftertaste at the back of
your throat
finally a couple of tablespoons of the
ginger syrup and then simply heat the
wine gently for four to five minutes to
infuse all the fantastic flavors but
don't let it boil or the alcohol will
evaporate and to go with that the most
amazing spiced nuts
[Music]
i love nuts so i'm using brazil's
almonds
walnuts
and hazelnuts
and then finally pistachios
lovely
really nice festive mix
as the nuts toast they start to release
their natural oils
then add a couple of pinches of salt
and then just let them
lightly toast
once the nuts start to color add half a
teaspoon of cayenne pepper which is made
from ground chilies
then sprinkle in half a teaspoon of
paprika a mild spice made from dried
pimentos for sweetness and depth
[Music]
and now you can see
the nuts
absorbing all that wonderful flavor
delicious finally put in a sprig of
rosemary
give the pan a good toss to make sure
all the nuts are thoroughly coated and
they're done
[Applause]
[Music]
christmas dinner wouldn't be complete
without brussels sprouts but when i was
a child they were boiled until horribly
soft
i want to keep my sprouts crisp vibrant
and fresh
sauteed with pancetta and chestnuts
these are sprouts like you've never
tasted before
and brussels sprouts are delicious when
they cook perfectly packed with texture
and the flavour is extraordinary
take off the outer leaves trim the
bottom and cut in half
that's a big step up from the crisscross
on the bottom that my mother used to do
every christmas
i'm cutting them in half so when i soda
them they cook evenly
and look
it's like little baby cabbages it's so
compact
then blanch them in salted boiling water
for two minutes
[Music]
now
this is the most amazing pancetta
lightly cured
pancetta is a type of italian bacon
which is brilliant for adding a lovely
rich meaty flavor to dishes i want a
really nice robust flavour
to go with that earthy texture
of the sprout
it's made from pork belly and is dry
cured with salt and aromatics like
juniper bay leaves nutmeg dry thyme and
garlic as it hits the pan that fat
on top of the pancetta melts and gives
the sprouts this amazing flavor after
removing the skin cut into small chunks
if you can't get hold of pancetta smoked
streaky bacon is a good alternative
now
hot pan
a teaspoon
of olive oil
give it a like seasoning with salt and
pepper
as the laven start to crisp up
take your sprouts
out
drain them
[Music]
sprouts in
now give that a really nice little toss
then chop up a handful of chestnuts
now the chestnut has sweetened the
flavor
of the sprout
really importantly you don't put the
chestnuts in too early otherwise they'll
go mush
and then just sprinkle
the chestnuts
over
lovely
so we've managed to turn a sort of plain
jane sprout
into something quite
delicious you've got the texture of the
smoked bacon the sauteed sprout
and that nice crunch
and sweetness of the festive chestnut
ten seconds before they come out lemon
zest
over
now that makes the sprouts and the bacon
harmonized
and then just a squeeze
of fresh lemon juice over the sprouts
beautiful
this right now is the ultimate
and for me that's a really nice modern
21st century
approach
to cooking an old-fashioned vegetable
with the sprouts done i'm ready to serve
my ultimate christmas dinner
making a stunning pork apricot and
pistachio stuffing the day before is a
great way to get ahead it's easy to do
looks a million dollars and tastes
absolutely delicious
christmas dinner for me is not about
food piled high on a plate less is more
i'd rather have five or six things on a
plate that tastes absolutely delicious
than 10 items tasting average
stuffing for instance
i'd much rather put a lot more effort
into the stuffing
and enjoy it but eat a lot less of it
first add pork mince to the bowl
season with salt and pepper and mix take
your grater
and a bravo and apple
just get the grater
and grate the apple in there
usually stuffing is cooked in the turkey
but i'm doing mine separately so i can
make in advance and get the flavor and
presentation spot on
now the nice thing about the apple it
goes brilliantly well with the pork it
makes it a little bit sweeter
it also makes it a lot lighter as well
which is really important
next add a handful of chopped apricots
which gives the stuffing another fruity
note and a lovely texture
the apple disintegrates but the apricots
stay really nice intact
nice little bite
then chop a handful of pistachio nuts
again
i'm thinking of the buildup of textures
flavor
and also
color
pistachios in
now give that a really good mix
grating some lemon zest the zest is
packed full of intensely flavored
essential oils which gives the stuffing
a vibrant citrus zing
[Music]
and for freshness add a handful of
coarsely chopped parsley
the balance of flavors
is nice and delicate and it sits
beautifully with a turkey
now
sage and pork and apple that's the
perfect marriage now i'm going to think
about the presentation skills tim fall
a little drizzle of olive oil
and then
we get a really nice
fragrant sage leaves
the sage leaves are used to wrap the
stuffing start by overlapping them
it's almost like rolling a cigar but
we're going to roll it
in sage leaves
taste is paramount but presentation is
really important too so it's worth
spending a few extra minutes to get this
right because it will make the final
dish look amazing
now a little season
across the top
[Music]
and then
take your sausage meat and we want to do
now is put half it
onto the
[Music]
i plate want to run your finger
along the stuffing
this is where it takes on a completely
different flavor again i need some spice
in there i want a little bit of heat in
the stuffing so it's exciting to eat
murgays murgays are traditional north
african sausages made from beef or lamb
and all we're going to do now
is take the sausage
and lay that
in the middle they're flavoured with
harissa a fiery chili paste which gives
them their heat and distinctive color it
really does give that nice sort of wake
up call inside the stuffing
if you can't get hold of merguez other
spicy sausages like srizzo would work
well too take the rest of the stuffing
and we'll sit that on top so in cases
that merge
[Music]
once you've got it like that
lift up the tin foil
very carefully
and roll that over
let the temple do the work roll it nice
and tight
there
fingers underneath
[Music]
just pull that back and double check
lovely
look at it it's not even cooked yet and
it looks delicious
the ultimate christmas cracker fantastic
that sage will cook and really perfume
the sausage meat and you cut through to
the center you've got a nice spicy
sausage lovely
in
now
roll it
across
twist at the ends
and then from there
up into the hands
and you push it in
and twist and turn
and all that's doing
is just making the perfect cylinder
beautiful
the stuffing can be made wrapped and
stored in the fridge a day or two in
advance
that's the first part of my ultimate
christmas dinner ready on christmas day
simply pop it into the oven and cook at
200 degrees for 40 minutes
[Music]
sources are one of the important ways
chefs add extra dimension and flavor to
dishes you can use this trick at home
my caramelized cranberry and applesauce
is another recipe i always cook a day in
advance
it packs a wonderful punch that really
lifts the subtle flavor of the turkey
it's simple to make and with its deep
red vibrant color looks fantastic on the
plate
the secret behind any good christmas is
in the organization and preparation
anything you can get done in advance do
it apple and cranberry sauce is a prime
example first things first we're gonna
make a really nice caramel
sugar in
add 150 grams of caster sugar to a pan
followed by a couple of star anise
that helps to really
give
a nice sort of aniseed flavor to the
cranberries
next lightly crushed four cardamom pods
this has a lovely warm spicy sweet
flavor
then wait for the sugar to melt and form
a caramel
really important at the conference now
to colour that caramel so it gets really
nice and dark before putting the
cranberries in
[Music]
wow
the smell of that caramel is amazing now
cranberries in
[Music]
crammies are very tired and acidic but
balance with the sweetness of the
caramel and apples they give the sauce a
lovely dry sharp note to tell if they're
fresh drop them on a hard surface the
higher they bounce the fresher they are
the cigarette now is sort of caramel to
blister
the cranberries and really start to
break that down
smells fantastic
next core peel and thinly slice two
apples
and once this sauce is finished it
really just helps to sort of wake up
the flavor of the turkey now the
cranberries are starting to break down
apple in
smells fantastic
a touch of salt and pepper that's really
important really helps to balance that
tartness against the acidity of the
apple salt pepper really brings it back
the smell is fantastic it's a sort of
sweet sour spicy nice
now from there
delays the pan with a touch of port
around the side
deglazing dissolves all the lovely
sticky caramelized bits of food that are
stuck to the pan and incorporates them
into the sauce
next add the zest of an orange
and for another layer of fragrant
sweetness squeezing the juice
lovely
then cook on a low heat for five to ten
minutes to thicken but remember the
sauce will become even thicker once it's
cooled down now that
is the right texture i don't want a
runny sauce i want something really nice
and thick delicious
packed full of flavor
perfect
if you really want to get ahead this
sauce can be made three or four days in
advance and kept in the fridge which
allows the flavors to develop even more
[Music]
then on christmas day simply bring it up
to room temperature and serve
another job done leaving you more time
to enjoy this very special day
[Music]
you